She's an American singer, songwriter and actress. Her first solo album sold 11 million copies.
She has won 120 Grammy Awards. She's Beyonce and here are her top 10 rules for success.
Everything that I've done. I've worked so hard from until my toes are bleeding and no complaints
so it takes so much hard work, and I think the more you have to work for something the more you cherish it and
Every time I think about doing something silly or something that's going to be detrimental to my career that I built I think about all
That time I've sacrificed in my childhood and my family and all the people that worked so hard and I could never
disrespect
All that I've worked for I could never disrespect my fans. I can never disrespect the opportunity that I've been [given]. I'm competitive
Really with myself right?
Honestly like I every time I start an album I
Go and watch all of my performances and I try to figure out
Okay, what is it that? I could have done better or what worked and
Really my references I go back to myself and try to better myself, so I'm really tough on
Me more so than than anyone else
I'm not a competitive person that walks in
Thinking about other people and how I can compete with them more especially not my husband I
I always was a creative child and I my parents encouraged it and I always
was doing something
creative. Whether it was writing songs or poems or making clothes or dancing, putting on shows.
Whatever. It was something creative. I think that that's so wonderful for kids. I think it just
It gives you so much
Confidence, and you just feel so good about yourself. You feel like you can accomplish
Anything and creativity can't be judged. So you just it just is great for self esteem for kids
Progression as an artist is [the] most important thing for me. That is what success is for me
I feel like if I stay in one spot. I'm not doing my job. I'm not growing as a human being and I'm
wasting time
And I feel like I always want to do something different from what I did in the past
I always want to challenge myself. I always want to have that nervous ball in my stomach before I go on the stage
That's how I know I'm doing the [right] job, and it's something still exciting for me
And I always want to challenge the music industry. I feel like it's kind of my job to create the new tempos
it's kind of my job to set the tone and
To be the example, so it's sometimes risky
But it's the only reason I've been able to
last for as long as I have in this industry because it's really short lived
And I feel like if people can predict your next move
It's just not interesting and I'll be bored. So, I'm bored and if I'm bored everyone else is bored.
I would say to continue to work hard and don't give up on your goals
And I know for me like I said I grew up watching my family
Struggle, and I grew up with a family that was
Successful, but not born successful
And I believe with hard work and with a goal
And love and positivity then eventually we're gonna be fine. I think a star is born a star
absolutely, I think I
Know me. I was born to do what I do
It's just too natural. There are certain [things] that I know. No one taught me. No one can teach you. It's just who
you are and
I
Feel like we all are stars. We all have that we just have to figure out what?
That thing is that we're supposed to be doing in life and I know that
For me to know exactly what [I] was born to do at such a young age is why I've been able to
do what I do as well as I do it because
I've been doing it for a really long time and I'm doing the right thing. Well, trust yourself know who you are um
Work very hard. How long did it take you and be able to trust yourself? Well, I was so young when I first started
It took a couple of years because [I] didn't know who I was. I was still a teenager. Yeah
But we always run our own songs and we always
you know
Had creative control for one because the label didn't really believe in us so they were like oh let them do whatever they want
And it worked out in my advantage because we proved ourselves at a young age, but I think
the biggest thing is
to
I would say rehearse, practice and
You know it doesn't matter if you're in front of Target, a day care wherever they say it takes 10,000
1000 hours
master exactly you would agree with that absolutely and I put the same amount of effort into
whatever I did and so did the other girls
It didn't matter what it was and eventually it prepares you for greatness
So work, work, work, work, work.
Sometimes we don't always feel beautiful. Sometimes we have our days where, you know, we feel under the weather or sad or
overwhelmed and I know for me, whenever I have those days, I try to
Put on my best outfit,  my best makeup and my sexy heels and when you look good
It makes you feel good, so I really know and my strong believe it when you're feeling down
You don't just stay in the bed and just you know soaking that you pull yourself together
And it is the beginning of overcoming whatever you're going through. There are many struggles um in
any career. This career, it's tough because
You always have to try to figure out what to do next and it's a lot of pressure
And I do so many different things. I'm always being pulled in so many different directions
So the worst thing is trying to make sure I keep
myself together and sane and I know who I am and
keep my life balanced. Still make time to
Spend with my family and my friends and still make time for my career. It's just trying to figure out that balance
It was very risky for me to step out on my own.
Being a young woman
I want to set the example that it's possible. For us to own our own businesses and own our own record labels and sometimes we don't
reach for the stars. Sometimes we are satisfied with what people tell [us]
we're supposed to be satisfied with and I'm just not going for it
Good morning
Does everybody know who everybody is? Alright, I'm Beyonce and I'm the president.
So I just wanted to have a creative meeting and
Figure out, you know, what the next direction will be
I booked the studio myself and paid for the studio myself and I
just had fun. I just did whatever I wanted to do
Thank you guys so [much] for watching. I made this video because
Chelsea Hilton asked me to
So if there's a famous entrepreneur you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Beyonce's top 10 rules
you like the most. Which one's resonated with you the most. Leave it in the comments below. I'm going to join in the discussion
Thank you so much for watching, Have a great day continue to believe and I'll see you soon